this whole like desperate need to be on
the left is so annoying that's why I'm
like you know I'll try and Define it
what does it mean to be culture War
right-wing economically right-wing or
socially right-wing definitions matter
but I'll refer to this as the freedom
faction or the culture War right like I
don't care what you call it so long as
we understand what we're talking about
anyone that's like I am a fill in the
blank I'm a conservative I'm a liberal I
am a this even I am an American like you
are putting yourself in a box man and it
is a dark hole you cannot see out of
that thing but is it a bonus hole
probably I'd be willing to bet that on
most issues I'm to the left of Hassan
hands down I hope he hears this I'd be
willing to bet that if we actually had a
discussion on issues I would be to the
left of him on a whole bunch of
different issues I'm not but he would
lie no no he would lie this is my point